Speaker 1: I am going to admit to you this next
story is a little bit confusing. The story is
about a montana Republican lawmaker who seemingly
suggested during a floor speech that she'd rather
her daughter kill herself, then transition to
being a trans male. Now, the confusing part of
this is we don't know whether this woman's
daughter actually is trans or has expressed
symptoms of gender dysphoria. We just don't know
because the clip is confusing. This is a state
representative from Montana, Carrie sequence. Crow
doesn't say her daughter is trans, but says her
daughter is or was suicidal for three years and
that she would rather her daughter be suicidal.
Then do the emotional manipulation that I guess
she considers claiming to feel as though you're.
A different gender would be in her mind. It's
definitely disgusting. It's obviously the type
of thing someone who shouldn't be a parent says.
But it is a little bit confusing. Let's listen.
Speaker 4: One of the big issues
that we have heard today and we've
talked about lately is that that without
surgery, the risk of suicide goes way up.
Well, I am one of those parents who lived with
a daughter who was suicidal for three years.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 4: Someone
once asked me, wouldn't I just do anything
to help save her? And I really had to think.
Speaker 1: The answer was no.
Speaker 4: And the answer was no.
Speaker 2: No.
Speaker 4: I was not going to give
in to her emotional manipulation because she was
incapable of making those decisions. And I had to
make those decisions for her. I was not going
to let her tear apart my family and I was not
going to let her tear apart me because I had to
be strong for I had to have a vision for her life
when she had none was incapable of having none.
Speaker 1: So she doesn't straight up say,
My daughter expressed that she's trans, but
she said it was an emotional manipulation.
And if your child is suicidal and you call it an
emotional manipulation, whether they're trans or
not, that's really something else. And remember,
these are the folks who want to decide who should
and shouldn't be parenting children. These are
the same folks who then will say, you know,
I don't think a gay couple should adopt or
should or shouldn't be able to, you know,
work with a surrogate or whatever. These are the
folks who want to tell everybody else how you
should and who should and shouldn't be allowed to
parent. This is like Westboro Baptist Church level
stuff. There is something called narcissistic
parenting. And you can Google this and read a
lot about it. When a narcissist focuses their lack
of empathy and their delusions of grandeur towards
their child. That's narcissistic parenting. And
sometimes narcissistic parents view their child
as an extension of themselves, of themselves. So
therefore, they say, well, the child exists for
my needs and therefore I'm going to say something
like, Oh, you're suicidal. Oh, you're saying that
you're trans. That's an emotional manipulation.
I'm going to decide for you this that the other
thing based on what I think is best for me right
now. Whatever the full details of this story are.
A disgusting woman who no doubt
claims to have the Moral Majority